hay fiesta árabe aquí en el estadio de
la ciudad de la educación por primera
vez en la historia de Marruecos avanza
unos cuartos de final lo hace aquí en
este mundial en el que están jugando
como local sin duda alguna Los Leones
del Atlas que empataron a cero con la
selección Española y después de 120
minutos de infarto el conjunto africano
se impuso una tanda de penales por tres
a cero la celebración de muchos
aficionados marroquíes que están aquí en
una presencia muy nutrida Carlos Sarabia
Pablo Pablo saraya Carlos solera y
Sergio busquet no pudieron convertir
para la selección española que terminó
esta tanda de penalti sin marcar ni un
solo gol por su parte de los marroquíes
no fallaron Y fue uno de sus mejores
jugadores sobre el campo ashraft hakimi
quien anotó el tanto decisivo que pone
por primera vez a esta selección entre
las ocho mejores de la Copa mundo un
partido en donde la primera parte fue
más igualada en donde ambos equipos
jugaron en un tercio del campo con las
líneas muy adelantadas para la segunda
parte Marruecos se metió más atrás y
España llegó a gozar de alguna que
oportunidad para abrir ese marcador un
disparo sobre el final de los 90 minutos
y al final de la prórroga un disparo al
palo de Pablo Sarabia aún así España
terminó con dos tiros a Puerta frente a
tres solamente de Marruecos los
marroquíes que seguramente van a
celebrar aquí en esta noche en doha